l'eau ne coule plus depuis des mois
c'est le résultat d'une politique
d'assèchement du lac sur lequel s'est
construit la capitale mexicaine ainsi
que d'un mauvais entretien des
canalisations et la situation se tend
avec la propagation du coït 10,9 dans
cet arrondissement défavorisés à l'est
de la ville au sein de la population de
la wac la patience face aux pénuries
d'eau incessantes est devenue une vertu
indispensable
je dis à mon mari va te laver
comment peut-il se laver s'il n'y a pas
d'eau ça devient vraiment fatiguant et
ça ne date pas d'hier bataille à gagner
ce gars là on nous a promis une
livraison cette semaine en attendant
cela fait deux jours que l'on n'a pas
une goutte d'eau mais aujourd'hui encore
me feel me dit qu'elle va faire la
vaisselle mais je lui réponds ma peur
aux filles j oublie qu'il n'y a pas
d'eau alors que l'épidémie de covile 19
atteint son pic au mexique
cette situation mais les autorités
locales sous pression face au
mécontentement croissant de la
population la municipalité de cloud
prétend vouloir assurer une distribution
d'eau équitable les pénuries d'eau même
sans urgence sanitaire pose des
problèmes de santé publique
aujourd'hui la situation s'aggrave et la
tension monte
bon nous l'idée d'organiser une réponse
qui s'applique dans plusieurs zones de
la ville afin que les habitants de ces
différents quartiers ne se voit pas dans
la nécessité de sortir de chez eux pour
aller chercher de l'eau car il nous
importe de faire appliquer les
différentes mesures d'hygiène
nécessaires pour endiguer les effets de
la pandémie
en absence d'eau courante l'eau arrive
par camion citerne pour éviter les
favoritisme et conflits entre voisins
ces livraisons sont désormais supervisé
par des employés de la mairie et face à
la multiplication des braquages de ses
camions la municipalité tient maintenant
à les faire escorter le canot que nous
suivons a pour destination le quartier
de la estación où tous les foyers ne
pourront pas être desservis aujourd'hui
c'est le cas de nathalie hernandez
quiros qui a jugé bon d'interpeller les
autorités locales ce matin là cette
situation est intenable
tous les habitants de ces rues sont dans
le même cas personne ne fait attention à
nous on doit continuer à sortir de chez
nous même si on nous recommande de ne
pas sortir car il est impératif pour
nous de régler ses problèmes de pénurie
d'eau nos enfants sont en bas âge et on
a besoin des cuisines et de laver notre
linge
on nous dit de nous laver les mains mais
comment est-ce possible si on n'a pas
d'eau on nous dit de nous laver les
mains toutes les 20 minutes toutes les
30 minutes
mais avec nos enfants qui sont à la
maison car ils n'ont pas content c'est
encore plus difficile que d'habitude
la progression toujours plus forte de
l'épidémie de cofidis 9 dans le pays
exige une action rapide
al'approche de la saison humide la
mairie de mexico mis sur un ambitieux
projet de captation de l'eau de pluie
afin de constituer des réserves d'eau
autonome dans les quartiers défavorisés